can you hear me yes it works okay
okay great so my name is Amir the
mirovic I'm an assistant professor at U
delft in the Netherlands
and I'm a person that's very excited
about algorithm development solver
development and essentially anything
that can help us solve very interesting
problems
so that's the perspective I'm coming
from here today
and in this talk what I want to do maybe
a bit different from some other talks is
that I want to talk about my experience
from the last 5-10 years how I've seen
the field develop and how I felt during
this time then try to extrapolate this
to see like how we should go further
so this talk is also partially based on
some projects that I recently started so
I think the things I'll be proposing are
actionable but some of the things will
be will be based on my opinion so you
might be disagreeing with it and in case
you have something to say I'm very happy
if you interrupt me and then we have a
discussion on it there
okay
there are three main points I want to
make in this talk one is that I believe
we need to embrace a unified view of
maxat CP and PB
I would argue that these paradigms are
not very conceptually different in fact
I would say they're all very
conceptually the same
and I think if we view them through a
unified View
we can get lots of algorithmic benefits
but also some clarity
and this doesn't mean abandoning our low
level view we can still use all the
views we want use all the information we
have
second point is which I label here the
slogan you are with your benchmark
it's more of a realization that
our benchmarks are very important for
the advancement of our field
and in some sense it's really the
becomes a core identity of our
communities
so since the techniques are not
conceptually that different we can
interchange them between different
paradigms
it seems like our our fields are mainly
our identity of a paradigm is actually
just based around our benchmarks
and then lastly I would also like to
argue that going forward asking for
scientific novelty might be the wrong
question
instead I would argue that we need to
focus more on scientific impact
and we will see that how these things
differ and then for all these three
points I'll give you some evidence and
some opinions and then we can talk about
that
all right
okay so most of the time I'll spend on
talking about the first part and then
we'll see how the second and third just
come out naturally from the first point
so just out of curiosity has anybody
been here to set 2013.
so this was a conference in Helsinki
a great deal there
and does anybody remember the talk of
Professor Peter stuck so Peter sucky is
a pioneering constraint programming he's
done a lot of work there
that's right so the talk was titled
there are no CNF problems
Professor Peter stack was invited to set
he went to sat where CNF is the Creed
and then he has a type talk saying there
are no senior problems bringing that
into question
and how do you think that was received
in the community
well let's say that Professor Peter
sucky was never invited to the set
conference again
foreign
I don't think you do receipts of invited
speakers I mean to be fair I think the
talk was well received right yeah
foreign
he also the reason his his sad coding
was better was because he used uh uh
Clauses that have that had block
variables which would which which in
processing would have deleted
it turns out that they helped
to propagate better
so they understand problems it seems
like Peter sucky is well versed in
creating CNF problems encoding
so we had this talk here and my talk has
a similar flavor but I'm coming from a
different direction
so I'm not going to say there are no
unit problems
instead I'm going to do a different View
and saying that you need to embrace more
of a unified View
and this is essentially saying that the
concepts are not they're not conceptual
difference between these paradigms
and to see that
we'll just have a look at how the field
developed let's say last period and then
we'll make some conclusions based on
that
but here we all know about cost analysis
a very core Concept in sat solving 2016
we had this graph paper on Clause
learning everybody knows that very very
impactful work
and then motivated by the success of
flaws learning CP people were saying
well okay
we need that too
so then there was this idea of quad
learning also in in CPA around for some
time but only around let's say 2007 or
2009 the professor Peter Stuckey or
fimenko and kodesh they came up with
something called lazy Clause generation
which we heard about before from Karen
and this essentially we're doing CP and
then we're plugging in the SAT confident
analysis
so it's really taking this analysis
plugging it in there
and then of course we've seen we've seen
PB solving we see also confidence as
being very important
so confident analysis transfers across
all these three fields okay
let's look at how we do optimization in
these in these paradigms the most
natural way of doing optimization is
querying some Oracle iteratively for a
better solution
a very natural way very straightforward
way of doing optimization this will be
called linear search and it comes out
with some several other names as well
but this is a very classic way how to
optimize things in CP nobody really ever
questions this kind of approach
but in Mexico this approach is rather
unpopular I would say until 2017.
and this is also interesting from my
experience I was working on some time
tables around 2003 2014
2013-14 now talk to different Max ad
practitioners and also submit to the
conference and get some reviews and so
forth and everybody's really surprised
that the best solver for my application
was sat 4J
and it was performing miles better than
any other solver at that time
everybody was you know a bit doubtful of
these results like have you seen the
recent competition have you tried this
core guided solver that core guided
solver which is a different technique
but somehow suffrage is running really
well and it turned out that it was
because
he was using this linear search
so even though it was somehow unpopular
the community it was still an approach
that could be used
and coincidentally in that period of
time we're also looking at how to
improve CP solving in research and we
came up with some ideas to simulate
local search and this performed really
well in CP and then we translated this
to maxite and it performed really well
in Mexico as well for incomplete solver
but here we see another example linear
search being translated across two
different paradigms
the other technique and this goes on and
on we have maxat Community we have this
core guided search algorithms so I think
this is something the next Community is
very proud of there are lots of
different these algorithms they're very
interesting and they worked really well
on the given benchmarks
and I'm motivated by that success we
took this idea we incorporated it in CP
we incorporated into suitable insult
then we looked at some combinations of
linear surgeon core guided search core
boosting and again worked really well in
maxat and working CP works also in PB
and then lastly maybe the last part I'm
going to talk about is this logic based
vendor's decomposition
so we've seen we've seen hooker himself
present this Workshop he was the
inventor of this technique in the 2000s
and the idea here that you somehow
decompose your problem in two parts and
you have some feedback loop between
these two parts
and the point here is you have to do
this manually
but maybe at this point unsurprisingly
this type of algorithm can also be
applied to Max set and it's now a very
popular technique under the name
implicit hitting sets
and we've seen it also being automated
in CP and then
perhaps makes a lot of sense that we've
also seen it perform really well into
the Boolean solve
another example
so to summarize maybe this short
historical progress we have an x-axis we
have the paradigms on the y-axis we have
the different techniques and now we look
at where have we applied which technique
and we see that all the boxes are
tickets
so we exhausted all these combinations
and how is it possible that we have
these different paradigms different
communities conferences and so forth
have these different techniques but they
all somehow seem to be applicable to
each other
so my conclusion was that these three
paradigms are not fundamentally
different really they are conceptually
the same the algorithms operate in very
similar ways every time we transfer
going to pick another we have to do some
work some something
but overall the spirit of the method is
really the same
so that motivates me to think about okay
if it's really like that then
well we know that we have different
views of the same problem we we know a
CPU offers let's say a high level view
of the problem set and PB offer low
level views so maybe when we solve
problems we're interested in solving
problems we should take into account all
this information when we do it
and this could help us find this
structure
a structure somehow
some elusive term we don't can't Define
what the structure means but somehow in
this Workshop we keep echoing how the
structure seems to be very important
so you've seen different talks like we
have the slim or LNS approach to maxat
let's find a good structure so we can
find better Solutions
saying maybe we should look at the
structure try to analyze what's going on
maybe cnf's not ideal maybe some other
View
and we also had yesterday a talk on bdds
and essentially it's about recovering
structure I think Nina stock was quite
interesting with this regard because
there we're also looking at the core
structure and trying to conclude
something
other structure is very important and we
also have it in algorithms too we have
different algorithms like detecting
cardinality constraints from a CNN
we have boundary variable addition we
have abstract cores and maxat and all of
this revolves around the concept that
there's some hidden structure in the CNS
that we have to recover and if we do
that we're going to get some really
really nice results
okay
but the nice thing here is that if this
problem like like Adam said if it comes
from somebody's head there is a high
level view of this problem and this is
given to us on a platter
so we know these definitions we have it
and then we can also decompose this into
our CNF view that's fine so we can just
keep both of these used and use that
high level structure if we know that the
problem has a lot of kernelity
constraints we can take that as a
starting point and then you can still
use our instruction recognition
algorithms because even if we have the
high level view we still might be
missing
some parts here
let's try to take both you and exploit
everything we have when we're solving
problems
and my point here is that also it's not
only important for like okay let's
exploit the structure but I think it's
also important for a way and how we
describe our algorithms I think if we
take a high level of you it may be
easier to describe what we're doing with
different people
and just give us a different perspective
so it doesn't necessarily remove the
lower level perspective just gives us a
different view of the same thing
to illustrate that I'm going to look at
or guided search approach so let's look
at a Max set problem and solve this core
guided search but with a CPU
I'm not going to solve the safety
techniques but just I'm going to look at
it from a CP perspective this is going
to be a quick example something some
details will be emitted but you'll get
the overall spirit
so here we have a Max step problem and
as as we've seen so far we typically
have units of Clauses in Max set which
nicely corresponds to object the linear
objective function
so here we have X1 x23 X4 all binary
variables
so what the idea of core guided search
is
does there exist an optimistic solution
is there some solution where all our
objective variables are set to the their
lower bounds
the answer is no
we get a Core which is a constant Clause
telling us some combination of these
initial optimistic assumptions do not
work
so then we have to take this into
account and what core got it serves does
it reformulates the instance to
explicitly take into account this new
piece of information that we have
and how we do that we create an integer
variable
it's the sum of the literals in our core
since since it came from a core we know
the lower bound is one
and then we use this integer to
reformulate our original instance
so we no longer have in the objective
function X1 X2 X3 that's encoded in our
integer variable y
and then we again have an optimization
problem and then we ask the same
question does there exist an optimistic
solution with respect to this new
problem
and this new problem is it's the same as
the original problem it just explicitly
has this new core information encoded in
it
and I would argue that this is a very
nice way of describing core guided
search we could also describe it using
Clauses but I think it will take me a
bit more time to explain that to you
so this is also another reason why this
high level view is very useful
and if you're really a Mexican person or
like a core guided search person you
might say okay it's not exactly the same
practice
here we have an inequality sign it's not
inequality
and the way we encode this here
well there are different ways to do that
and then depending on the way we do it
we're going to refer to different
Mexican algorithms
but still
this doesn't include all the techniques
but give us a very nice view of how
things are done and this is a very
similar way in how we actually do core
guided search in in CP
the main point is that we have this high
level view that we can use to to really
see what's going on and maybe even
exchange information with each other
and this the following one is also very
interesting so since we have these
different views but since they're
conceptually the same sometimes we can
test some folklore that's going around
in the community
so we know that let's say you have a new
problem
you have a new specific problem you want
to solve and then you come to a set
solving person and you say look I have
this new problem can I give you a
variable selection heuristic this will
surely improve the performance
it's not solving person will probably
tell you no
no we don't touch that
we have very good heuristics instead
we we don't change them for specific
applications
however in CP it's really the opposite
so if we have a new problem and somebody
says do you have acoustic yes give us
the heuristic give us this domain
specific knowledge that we can use
and both of these experiences are valid
so we've seen many times where this
where this is really like that but if
the if these paradigms are not that
conceptually different how come these
this these experiences are still there
so who is right here in the end and why
I think we get these lots of these kind
of questions if we view this through
this common lens
overall with this with this first part I
want to argue here is that we have this
high level view of the problem let's
embrace it let's celebrate this and
let's exploit this to do
to get better algorithms and to also
maybe explain our techniques on a higher
level and get the message across faster
and here are the lucky the nice thing
here is that
it's not about techniques subsuming each
other or paradigms subsuming each other
it's really about exploiting all the
information we have to solve our
problems
but then the question here is that okay
if these if I am right that really the
conceptually they are not different
they're the same then why do we have
this divides in our community
we have some people we have CP people
maybe also PB people
why do we have this divide
if the techniques can be interchanged
that's not the defining Factor anymore
and as I hinted in the beginning
it's really about the benchmarks
so the benchmarks they shape the
identity of our community so when we say
we're a set-solving person well we're
actually a person that solves that
benchmarks that appear in the set
community
I think this is a very important
realization
that's why I say you are what you
benchmark
so if we want to find some portal
between the communities
maybe it's not the language that
communities are using maybe it's really
about the benchmarks
however despite this importance of these
benchmarks and despite them having such
uh I would say maybe even implicit but
very impactful role
typically we don't really support
Benchmark Developers
and this is here where I want to tell
you my personal story about my
experience with this kind of uh issues
and I think this issue is going to be
quite serious
so back when I was starting my PhD I was
a very enthusiastic person I started I
was very happy to work on something
called High School timetable yeah
enthusiasm goes down over time doesn't
it
and you'll see one of the reasons too so
I was super interested in high school
timetabling I thought I generally
thought this was the most important
problem in the world there's so many
high schools in this the world and
everybody needs to solve this problem
and I had personal connection to the
problem too because I was studying
computer science and music and I had and
every semester there were lots of
clashes in between these subjects and
then I had to disentangle this somehow
and I got to know the timetablers
and I could really see that the job they
had to do was was really really tedious
and nobody was ever happy with whatever
they did
so I was a computer science student so I
thought well great computers are good at
Computing this looks like a Computing
problem
let's let's try to do that let's use
computers to solve High School time tip
so I was very enthusiastic and I was
working on this and coincidentally there
was a competition in high school I think
in 2011.
people came up with a very general time
dealing formulation 16 constraints every
constraint has some various parameters
there were benchmarks for all across the
globe South Africa Australia Brazil
really you name it and surprisingly
every country has a completely different
required set of requirements
so I tried out different techniques
different things and eventually I
somehow got to maxat and I tried Max set
and I was getting really good results so
it was really beating the The
Competition winner
oh great what a success story such a
complex problem it's being solved by
maxette fantastic surely the set
community would be very interested in
this this kind of achievement
how do you think that was received
it was really a disaster so I submitted
this paper several times and
overall the general sentiment that you
get from the reviews are good reviews
high quality they're good comments but
the general sentiment is this is not
interesting
there's limited novelty here
and we have some other problems that
generally have this timetabling keyword
in the title so we don't need more
and you know as a enthusiastic PhD
student starting very vulnerable period
you're looking for some recognition and
then you just kind of get cut down like
that
it's a very disappointing thing but I
submitted these benchmarks to the maxite
evaluation and they've been there for
over five years great they've been
useful please take these looking at
these benchmarks I was got inspired and
some of the things I talked about before
I got the inspiration looking at those
benchmarks so I think those benchmarks
are very useful and this was really
useful to success story but somehow I
wasn't appreciated even though the
benchmarks are really helping us develop
these techniques
and why was it like that it's because
of this idea of scientific novels so
what is scientific novelty so that was a
novel solving such a great problem
and I also had another experience
and don't worry it won't be all about my
experiences I have some other stories
too I collected so another one is that I
have this idea of
looking at the solution guided search it
was kind of floating around the
community I packed it up nicely we tried
it in CPR let's try it in Max set wow
amazing results including complete track
surely the community will be interested
in these results
I submitted that and it's again the same
story
there's limited novelty and The Meta
reading The Meta viewer even cited a
paper which is true it uses a very
similar technique but in different
context in the context core guided
search where that technique made very
little difference
but in my case it made a lot of progress
so then the paper was rejected and you
know that makes sense it's really not
novel in that sense but fast forward now
five years and essentially all the
solvers and incomplete track are using
either solution guided search or some
variation of that technique
so we had so much success with it Alex
nadell took it gave his spin on the idea
and now other other solvers are now kind
of combining different solvers and so we
could say that in the end it was rather
useful for The View
and then last cup meeting called the
meal was complaining that his paper got
rejected from cow because it was only
engineering work
right nothing nothing new there just
engineering rejected and he submitted it
to some other conference and it got the
nomination for best Pay Pro
and if those
these stories were not convincing maybe
the following one would be quite
interesting I think everybody knows
about the mini set paper
last year in the last set conference the
staff Community decided to give an award
to the minister paper as the 20 years
influential award something like that
it's a most cited set paper there is
and admin beta was giving a talk instead
of the authors and he recalled a story
that when mini set paper was being
published
what was the reviewer attitude towards
the paper
a reject
it's not novel we don't need this it's
not new
so here you look at these stories and
you see how most of the techniques that
we developed like how we developed
things like in maxat cpnpb you could
also argue like whether those ideas were
novel or not You could argue and here in
a sense yeah you could also argue with
these things are not
so I think it's debatable so there's
views what is novelty we can talk about
that but I think what we can agree on is
that okay we maybe don't know what a
novel is but we can agree that these
things were very impactful
definitely there's an impact that helps
the community develop
so for that reason I think that
we shouldn't be asking necessarily for
scientific novelty if
novelty is necessary for progress
but maybe the main thing we should be
looking for is how to make this
scientific impact
and with that I'm coming into my talk
so these will be the three points that I
had so one is let's Embrace this
unifying view it's at cppb and overall
part this really the same story same
techniques everything the same in that
sense on a high level of course
we can use the high level view to get
some structural insights to use some
algorithmic benefits and also
communicate maybe easier to each other
you are with your benchmarked benchmarks
is very important if you want to merge
the communities if you need to find ways
how can we merge the benchmarks in a way
that's very accessible to everybody
and lastly let's
you know sign technology is great but
maybe scientific impact is our actually
main goal
thank you and uh be great if you have
some questions and comments
[Applause]
there's lots of other paradigms that are
not included here yeah I forgot to
mention it so here I'm just focusing on
Sat cppv but if you're working in smt or
ASP or some other Pro you might see that
yeah there is similar things going on
there also in terms of whether they're
conceptually different in terms of
benchmarking and all these other
I agree with that
nobody has any comments to this
I cannot believe that
I'm going to say something something
similar if if you put MIP up there I
think you would find conceptually
different I I mean
some communities
use different analogies when they talk
to each other they tell different Jokes
which I mean I think there are there is
a difference
yeah so this I agree with so ILP I think
is something I think it's further away
let's say a little bit
but in terms of like Max at CP and PB I
think that they're much closer than
how do you propose we judge impact
before we've had 10 years to see what
people do with something
yeah so this is uh so the question is
like how do we judge impact so on one
hand we have the scientific idea now I'm
saying okay let's not do that you'll
Define thing maybe impact is better
defined I think it's a bit more
difficult
um to really just Define what it is but
some things we can understand like the
giving a really good success story very
good Benchmark for example said maybe
that's something we know it'll be useful
because good benchmarks are really what
we need that's maybe an example of let's
say something that's impactful but you
could discuss whether it's like novel if
you have these engineering improvements
why they're useful because they might be
impactful and impact could also be from
the theory side too it's like impacts
our understanding and and so forth
so I think it's not necessarily A
something also we can well Define but I
think it's a bit easier to discuss
maybe the impact of certain work is
rather than this novelty
I mean I say this because for about 10
years in the UK we had to adjust if my
scientific impact upon Any Grant
application
and it ended up being such a waste of
time that the idea was finally abolished
a couple of years back because I mean
there is no way of telling what's going
to be impactful until yeah but for
example in these examples here you see
these things and and what do you think
are they novel I don't know but are they
impactful
would you have said that at the time
okay but again yeah I agree it's a it's
a collective thing it's we have to
decide kind of somehow
yeah Jacob had something over there yeah
so I I agree with so I am really missing
MIP among the you know sad CP and PB I
think
for me like one of the really things I
get away from a week like this is true I
I believe these are different
communities they have different ideas
but what I think happened when they talk
to each other and what we're maybe
missing out on because I mean sad CP PB
smt people do talk to each other I think
we're not talking so much to the or
Community I'm trying to understand why I
think we're missing out on something
there because I think all your examples
are like these were actually ideas that
did arise
in different communities that are
conceptually different I think these
communities do have conceptually
different use of these problems but when
communication happens like you can steal
the best ideas from your neighbor
communities and Implement them in your
setting with some tweaks and then it
works for you as well so it's like I
would I would uh say that it's an
argument in favor you know of
communication and diversity they are not
all the same they should not be but we
there's a huge benefit from
communication and understanding yeah I
definitely agree there's benefit from
communication and we do talk to each
other that's how I came up with those
ideas for example for me importing from
one Paradigm to another but still when
we do certain analysis like we look at
the CNF level for example can we extract
some analysis on the CNF level for some
real world problems like we've seen Nina
stock for example there was these cores
and and if you look at the name of the
Benchmark it said that most 24 out of 55
but we don't see that in the Benchmark
we just see the CNF version
and we don't have let's say too much
from like we don't have any benchmarks
or you have both views for example it's
usually one or the other
so I think it's something that we could
look towards
yeah I I I'm certainly not against
diversity
um but but but but
uh
I I think some Community are are based
on paradigms and some communities are
based on goals and and and that's based
on like you know to take health or
something so we want to use any any
trick that anybody knows in order to
improve People's Health but but uh but I
find that um uh uh
physicists think different from
mathematicians
I mean I mean algebra is think different
from geometry I I I I I I don't want to
emphasize the differences but but there
are but but I don't want to say that
there are such differences I I I I I I
you know so Viva difference but but but
uh I I don't think uh
we're going to get
um
many people who who have their their
feet you know in all camps so so I you
know I I I'm glad to be at a university
where you know where I've got I've got
physicists to call on and biologists to
call on musicians to call on whatever
um uh uh
like and uh historians and et cetera uh
but uh but
um but I also want to have students who
are uh who who have certain talents uh
that I can develop their talents because
I don't think it it's my function to
teach them to teach them to change their
their own style of of thinking
okay that's a good point but here then
the nice thing with I think with this
unified view we don't have to give up on
our way of thinking if we like to think
on CNF let's do that but let's also keep
in mind this other high level
so let's just try to do everything
can I have a comments on the first point
oh excellent yeah so I found that um
it's not that easy to synchronize
information between two constraints uh
to Canada concern for example you have a
highlight constraint low level
constraint it's easier to infer like if
you have uh in for some assignment it's
either to synchronize information from
low level to high level but
but if you learn a cloth if you learn
some constraint from the you know Halal
constraint it's very hard it's time
consuming if you pass this information
to low level you have to break this high
level constraint into low level and also
if you learn a constraint from low level
constraint and it's also like a Time
consumed if you compose multiple learn
Cloud learn constraint like to pass it
into high level
so like this kind of and communication
is very time consuming in practice
okay that's a good point